you know why I'm so kind of Blown Away
by your career it's not only the music
it's like the film industry you know I
think like 9 to5 I never even seen a
movie made till then and I'm sure you
know the story of how I memorized the
whole script like it was a play I didn't
know but I it help it helped me though
cuz I was way ahead of the game I had
been offered movies uh before that but I
didn't want to do it and then when Jane
came to me with that idea I thought well
Jane fond is a really big star and so
was Lily I thought well if it's a hit
then I can just you know bask in the
glory with them and if it's a failure I
can just blame it on them nobody knows
me that well did you hold off doing
movies because you said look I've got a
great singing career I've I've got lots
of Goodwill out there if I'm in some
crap movie I'll be a laughing stock so
there's some fear in it right that
holding you back no it wasn't even that
I just wasn't interested at that time
cuz nothing good enough had come along
to to make me think that I would be
willing to give up my music and my
touring and all that
uh Jane just said you just be yourself
and then you know all you really got to
know is you know where your marks are
hit your lights hit your marks and all
that so um it wasn't hard to be myself
and I thought that little character was
so so me that I didn't have to act
really I just I just performed and I got
to write the SE theme song for it and
and become famous for for that as well
as the movie being such a big hit and
I'm that thing just lives and on I
eventually later went on and wrote a
musical the Broadway musical the music
for that that was some theme
[Music]
song you know that I wrote that song you
know with my nails you know like I was
going to ask you about that yeah how do
you do that c rer you know were you
sitting in your I don't know where where
were you sitting in your in waiting
around on movie said I was so uh
Starstruck being you know just watching
how a movie is made even if I wasn't in
the scene I was there every day cuz I
wanted to watch it so I would just be
watching what the other girls were doing
what the scenes were and I would just be
thinking you know like working on and I
would watch whatever was going on and I
would just be like you know cuz I
couldn't get a guitar out on the set so
I would just kind of you got to have
acrylic nails to make that real
percussive sound but I would just I
thought it sound like a typewriter can
you hear
that what a way to make living barely
then I would write uh verses I'd write
things and then I'd go back to my hotel
night and get my guitar out and then I'd
put it down on on tape and I wrote it
over a period of of of weeks you know
the whole song before I actually sat
down and then just assembled it and put
it all together but I thought that sound
like a typewriter and I actually played
my nails on the
you know on on the thing I was working
with a guy named Greg Perry who produced
the uh the 95 song and he's now going to
be arranging a lot of the music for my
Broadway musical that I'm going to be
doing uh next year so I thought life
just kind of goes around it 40 years
since you know since that happened uh
and now he's you know I'm going to
actually be working with him again but
he's he's the one who got that
typewriter out and thought well your
nails sound like a top Rider so let's
just use a typewriter to actually start
the you know the the actual song and so
he said when we got ready to record it
he said let's just put you on the nails
my dolly just for fun so it was
great